[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas si longtemps
il nous aurait pas été possible de se
rassembler ce soir comme nous le faisons
dans cette salle
il n'y a pas si longtemps et sans aucune
transition on s'est retrouvés confinés
dans nos maisons éloignés de nos proches
et sans aucune transition s'est aussi
retrouvé face à la décision de faire ou
pas un vaccin et face à l'obligation de
porter un masque
sans aucune transition
certaines de nos libertés ont été
suspendus
vous êtes vous déjà posé la question de
ce que seraient nos libertés dans un
monde où le changement climatique serait
de plus en plus impactants
je vais leur formuler différemment alors
que nous avons nos restrictions
sanitaires encore fraîche dans nos têtes
esprit est ce qu'il serait envisageable
qu'un jour on serait tellement sous
contraintes climatiques qu'on aurait des
restrictions climatique
et je pose donc cette interrogation ce
soir
la transition bas carbone une économie
bas carbone où sont les transitionnelle
et pour ce faire
puisque je considère que malheureusement
ou heureusement pour certains et
malheureusement pour moi en tout cas la
science influence de moins en moins nos
opinions et nos décisions et j'ai pris
le parti ce soir de répondre à cette
interrogation de base en
prenant une équation mathématique et
donc en passant par une explication
rationnelle scientifique
cette équation on la doit à
un japonais une économiste japonais qui
a mis en place en 1993 ce qui s'appelle
maintenant l'équation de kaya et cette
équation
se veut démontrer la façon dont nous
devons travailler ensemble pour réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre le
co2
alors d'emblée ça peut faire un peu peur
mais c'est très simple en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je vois la mathématique
c'est un langage
donc si vous lisez avec moi de gauche à
droite
c'est simple ça dit qu'il ya des
certaines quantités et sur un contraste
concentration des émissions de co2 dans
l'atmosphère parce que nous utilisons
des sources d'énergies fossiles que ses
sources d énergies fossiles servent à
produire des biens et des services
lesquels biens et services nous les
utilisons nous les consommons
je le relis de la même façon mais cette
fois-ci de droite à gauche il y a une
population mondiale dont une certaine
partie consomment et produisent une
certaine quantité de richesse ont un
niveau de bien-être de confort ça dépend
de ce que vous préférez et que ce niveau
de bien être et de confort et produit
par certains types d'énergies fossiles
qui émettent du co2 voilà tout ce que
dit cette équation et voilà tout ce
qu'on a besoin de savoir pour ce soir il
y aura pas de calcul ça sera simple
un conte qui éclaire aussi dans cette
équation c'est qu'il ya trois système
qui est mis de l'avant le système
énergétique
le système économique et le système
démographique et que ces trois systèmes
interconnectés à pâques la concentration
des émissions de co2 le premier système
qui se veut être sur la partie
énergétique
et 7 cette production va dire d'énergie
qui émettent certaine quantité de co2 le
premier le premier rapport co2 par nrj
on l'a pris l'habitude de le dire dans
le langage international que c'est le la
composante énergie renouvelable et donc
on a une solution pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ont
choisi de d'utiliser des sources
d'énergie qui émettent moins de co2 des
énergies propres et cette première
solution est une bonne nouvelle
puisqu'elle nous permet de réduire et la
bonne nouvelle c'est que aujourd'hui
après tant d'années transition
énergétique
on est arrivé à simplement à empiler les
énergies renouvelables au dessus des
énergies fossiles il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de substitution au point où 85%
en moyenne au niveau mondial de la
production énergétique vient d énergie
gaz charbon pétrole fossile contre 20 à
25 % au niveau des énergies
renouvelables c'est une solution mais
elle n'est pas à n'a pas été activée
assez vite la deuxième solution qui est
celle de l'efficacité énergétique ici en
jaune
permet en fait de rendre notre mode de
production un peu plus efficace on
construit des équipements qui vont
consommer moins d'énergie pour faire la
même production
on fabrique de l'électroménager dans vos
maisons pour pouvoir améliorer cette
performance est donc c'est une bonne
solution parce qu'on consomme moins
d'énergie pour un même niveau de
produits au même niveau de service la
bonne nouvelle que je peux dire aussi
par rapport à cette composante c'est que
au fil des années on a amélioré
l'efficacité énergétique
et en même temps d'améliorer
l'efficacité logistique on s'est rendu
compte qu'en fait la population s'est
dit puisque j'améliore je peux avoir non
pas un mais deux trois réfrigérateurs ou
à aux deux ou trois smartphones puisque
je gagne en efficacité et que le produit
de plus en plus efficaces donc sur ces
deux composantes qui sont deux solutions
tout à fait plausible la
la composante énergie renouvelable et la
composante efficacité énergétique on en
revient à dire que le la solution et
technologiques et qu'elle nous permet en
fait de mettre en place un développement
durable une croissance durable et comme
vous voyez j'ai mis des contraintes à
ces deux solutions est une contrainte
aussi qui arrivent bientôt c'est cette
contrainte de ressources de matériaux
qui va rendre encore plus compliqué les
énergies renouvelables et l'efficacité
énergétique des matériaux qu'on appelle
des métaux rares et qui vont nous
emmener à être sur des tensions
géopolitiques pour savoir qui va obtenir
ces métaux et qui va en fait aller plus
vite dans la transition énergétique
il me reste à parler des deux derniers
composantes et là on entend une
complexité en fait par rapport à ses
composantes parce que en fonction de
vous de là où vous placez en fonction de
l'individu ou le professionnel ou
l'économiste ou que sais-je dans la
société on arrive en fait à avoir des
complexités que beaucoup n'ont pas voulu
aborder sur la population il est clair
que l'idée n'est pas de réduire la
population
ou de diviser par 10 par je ne sais
quels moyens mais de prendre en
considération que sarah l'impact et
qu'en fait en fonction de là on se situe
si on est un individu comme moi par
exemple j'ai toujours en grand débat
avec ma femme si on fera quatre autres
fois où je regarde le premier qu'on a
déjà mais c'est pas anodin c'est
vraiment pas anodin parce que peut-être
car maurice c'est pas tout à fait
exploser mais il ya bien une génération
dans le monde qui se pose la question
d'un front t ou pas dans un monde sous
climat ce stress climatique
la composante de la 2e économie pas
présente en rouge sur que j'ai souligné
ici vient bien démontré que on utilise
de l'énergie pour faire le système
économique pour produire des biens et
des services et ça ça me rappelle une
phrase que disait toujours mon prof
d'économie en école d'ingénieur et à
l'époque j'avais strictement rien
compris à ce qu'il disait parce que moi
je suis intéressé à poser des panneaux
solaires lui il disait vous verrez
l'économie ce n'est ni plus ni moins que
de l'énergie transformée
il n'y a pas d'économie sans
transformation d'énergie
et dans le monde dans lequel on arrive
avec les patients énergétique qu'il y a
on se rend compte que de plus en plus il
ya des modèles de développement des
modèles qui sont préconisés par les
scientifiques par des idées groupe
d'économistes par les politiques et ils
annoncent cela comme étant de la
sobriété
c'est à la mode alors que vous vous
appelez sa sobriété que vous l'appelez
décroissance que vous l'appelez néo
libérale capitaliste
peu importe mois à la limite ça
m'intéresse pas l'idéologie qui a
derrière de la façon dont on veut
atteindre un niveau de confort et quel
est le niveau de confort qu'on souhaite
pour une société ce qui moi intéresse
c'est que factuellement scientifiquement
il est clair qu'on arrive face à un
problème que ce soit le problème pris
dans le sens de réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre où que ce soit dans
le sens qu'il ya bientôt plus de sources
d'énergie pour répondre à notre système
économique et pour faire cela il faut
trouver des nouvelles solutions de
nouvelles aptitudes de nouvelles idées
il faut reconnaître qu on part sur un
point de bascule entre des solutions
traditionnelles et classiques et des
solutions qu'on n'a pas vous jusqu'à
présent abordé est rentré en fait dans
cette transition c'est pour ça que
j'appelle à avoir des transitionnelle
qui accepte d'aller à un livre un nouvel
état un nouvel état et comme j'ai dit
que je parlais de science je voulais
juste très très rapidement dire quelque
chose sur la mécanique quantique quand
vous observez la matière et que la
matière et est soumis à un état de
chaleur on dit que la matière est excité
et que dans cet état d'excitation la
matière ne peut pas produits à grand
chose par contre quand vous observez la
même matière dans un état beaucoup plus
froid la matière développe de nouvelles
propriétés des propriétés qui n'était
même pas visible quand elle était
soumise à la chaleur
l'assurance après ça le froid absolu ce
soir je voudrais juste l'appeler
notre être intérieur
puisque cette composante rouge là nous
appelle forcément à devenir à nous
questionner nous à notre propre
intérieur la science appelle le zéro
absolu le froid absolu moi je n'oserais
même peut-être la plaie ce soir notre
aide spirituelle que nous avons bien
souvent délaissée pour prendre les
décisions
que nous reste-t-il à faire en fait
il est important maintenant de joal ses
nouvelles aptitudes qui vont nous
permettre de mondialiser ce qui doit
être mondialisé et de démondialiser ce
qui doit être démondialiser de croître
ce qui doit être grande crois tu es de
décroître ce qui doit l'être aussi et de
pouvoir également enveloppé ce qui doit
l'être et à la fois développer on rentre
dans cette complexité là et
je réalise en fait que pour le faire on
a vraiment besoin d'un collectif de se
rassembler d'être ne plus possible
collaboratif en concertation et de lever
toutes les énergies possibles afin de
respirer ensemble il nous reste la
dernière bulle d'air la science nous dit
pour respirer ensemble et avoir cette
solution dont nous avons besoin nous
avons la tête suffisamment au bord de
l'eau le climat est suffisamment frais
pour le faire maintenant et quand vous
allez à la racine des mots respirer
ensemble ça veut dire conspiré
à la racine des mots je vous appelle ce
soir à la plus grande conspiration qui
nous reste à faire en tant qu'humanité
tigha
yaka
callas je dirais même mieux y'a plus
qu'à
merci
[Applaudissements]